hey everyone
welcome back to another video on the
angular series
in this session we're going to cover the
topic of what
is angular i'm sure all of you use
mobile and web applications
be it from social media to health care
e-commerce and net banking
these apps are used by billions of
people across the globe
now the main reason we use these apps is
that they
offer seamless user experience and
interface
but how are they developed to provide
such reliability
one of the frameworks that is widely
used to build such robust
apps is angular so let's dive into the
session now
so here is a list of topics that we're
going to be covering
first up we'll see why angular was
introduced
then what is angular features of angular
angular architecture advantages and
limitations of angular
the learning curve of angular and
finally we look at some of the companies
that deploy angular
so without further delay let's begin
why angular now javascript is the most
commonly used client-side scripting
language
it is written into html documents
enabling interactions with web pages in
many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost
pervasive support it is exceptionally
well suited to develop modern
applications
but the question arises is javascript
ideal for developing single page
applications that require modularity
testability and other features perhaps
not however we have a variety of
frameworks and libraries
designed to help us with such things
with respect to front-end development
angular and javascript together bring in
structure and consistency
to your web applications and also
provide scalability and maintainability
angular is specifically developed for
single page applications
so now the question arises what exactly
is
angular angular is an
open source javascript framework written
completely in typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications
and is maintained by google angular as a
framework
provides a few advantages while also
providing a standard structure for
developers
it is designed for web desktop and
mobile platforms
if you have a doubt here as to what
exactly single page applications
are let me help you with that now these
single page applications
are basically applications that get
loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions
does not lead to loading of subsequent
pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already loaded
page
so these single page applications are
primarily developed using angular
moving ahead let's look at the features
of angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing we have the document
object model
type script data binding and testing now
let's look at them
one by one now the document object model
treats an xml or an html document
as a tree structure now here every node
in the tree structure
defines an object representing a part of
your document
angular uses the regular dom now let's
suppose you've made
10 updates on a single html page
so every time you make a change the
corresponding
dom or the tree structure needs to be
updated
now angular updates the entire tree
structure of html tags
moving on to our next feature we have
typescript
now typescript defines a set of types
to javascript which helps you write
javascript that is
easier to understand now all the
typescript code compiles down to basic
javascript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is not
mandatory for developing an angular
application but it is highly recommended
the main reason is highly recommended is
that it offers better syntactic
structure
while making the code base easier to
understand and maintain
now typescript can be installed as an
npm package
now to do that you just have to run the
command npm install hyphen g
type script on your command prompt next
up is data binding now data binding is a
process
that allows you to manipulate web page
elements
using the web browser now it mainly
employs dynamic html
and does not require complex scripting
or programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials games etc now incremental
display
of a web page makes data binding
extremely convenient
when pages contain a large amount of
data
when it comes to angular it uses two-way
data binding
so any changes made in the ui element
is reflected in the corresponding model
state
and conversely any changes made in the
model state
are reflected onto the ui state this
allows the framework to connect the term
to the model data via the controller
the last feature we're discussing is
testing
angular uses jasmine to run its various
tests
the jasmine framework allows various
functionalities
to write different kinds of test cases
karma is a task runner
for the tests that use a configuration
file
to set the startup reporters and testing
framework
so with that we've covered the features
of angular
so let's go ahead and understand the
architecture of angular
now angular is a full-fledged mvc
framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured
and offers bi-directional data flow and
updates to real dom
mvc short for model view controller
is an architectural pattern that
separates the application layer into
model
view and controller the model here
relates to
all the data related logic view on the
other hand
is used for ui logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and view on let's look at the advantages
of angular
first up we have custom components
angular allows you to build your own
components
that can pack functionality along with
rendering logic
into reusable pieces data binding
as discussed angular allows you to
effortlessly move your data
from your javascript code to the view
and react to user events
without having to write any code
yourself
dependency injection angular allows you
to write
modular services and have them injected
wherever they are needed
this greatly improves the testability
and reusability of the same
don't worry if you can't wrap your head
around these topics
we're going to discuss them further in
the coming videos
next advantage is testing angular has
been built from the ground up
with testability in mind you can
literally test
every part of your application
comprehensive
angular is a full-fledged framework and
provides
out-of-the-box solutions for server
communication
routing and more lastly we have
excellent browser compatibility
angular is cross platform and browser
compatible
an angular application can typically run
on all browsers
beat chrome firefox safari and platforms
like windows mac os
and linux now many versions of angular
have been released
ever since its inception all of these
versions
have added to the efficient working of
the framework
now here are two different versions
released first up
was angular 1. it was built on
javascript
and completely based on controllers next
release
was angular 2. now this incorporated the
component based approach
where in the entire ui was divided into
several components
and lastly integrated to give the final
logic
next was angular 4 it included router
updation
angular cli or command line interface
1.0 was introduced
however not deployed in this release the
angular cli was optimized
and commands like ng update and ng add
were added
in the angular 7 release prompts were
introduced
which provided tips in cli about the
functions being used
in angular 8 iv renderer and bazel were
introduced
and finally the most recent release was
angular 9.
now this came with the better framework
and angular material
now this completely switched to the iv
renderer as a default compiler
now that we've learnt about the pros of
using angular let's look at some of the
limitations of angular
first up is a sleep learning curve now
since
angular is a complete full-fledged
framework
it becomes difficult for learners to
begin with
you need to be acquainted with simple
topics and then move on to more advanced
topics to become proficient in this
language
next up is limited seo options now
angular offers limited seo options and
poor accessibility to search engine
crawlers
it's verbose and complex now a common
issue
faced by the angular community is the
verbosity
of the framework it also poses to be
complex compared to other front-end
tools
and lastly migration now one of the
drawbacks of angular
is poor migration now it becomes
difficult
to port legacy code to angular style
architecture
also with each new release it is painful
to upgrade
and a lot of them are not backward
compatible
next up let's look at the angular
learning curve
now if you wish to learn angular you
need to be acquainted
with basic topics in angular some of
them
are directives modules decorators
components services dependency injection
pipes and templates now once you've
mastered your basics you will want to go
and understand
more advanced topics such as change
detection
zones aot compilation and rx.js
however the learning curve of angular is
clear-cut
in the beginning it could be a little
intimidating but once you start using
the tool
it becomes way more easier to comprehend
and understand what is going on
and lastly let's look at some of the
companies that use angular today
many top tier companies like nike forbes
google hbo sony up work among others
readily deploy angular so with that
we conclude the session i hope it was
informative
if you have any doubts or questions let
us know in the comment section below
thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos
on this series on angular until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here